mit ihrem einsatz belegen wir kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
auf das neue stück paradise city ein
musical mit lauter schweizer eurovision
schoss
mit dabei christoph marti und tobias
bonn von der legendären
schweizerisch-deutschen kabarettgruppe
geschwister pfister
[Musik]
sie ist mal gesehen und ich einmal aus
dem weg
und s
wer kann mir
swiss lady natürlich kennen sie das lied
willkommen auf den kulturplatz 1977
holte damit pepe lienhard mit seiner
band den sechsten platz beim eurovision
de la chanson
heute heißt das ja weit weniger melodiös
eurovision song contest
wir sind dabei kurz vor der uraufführung
eines musicals und dieses crêpes tief in
der schatzkiste des eurovision song
contest wenn das nur gut kommt
[Musik]
paradise city so heißt das neue stück am
konzert theater bern und dieses setzt
ausschließlich auf eurovisions beiträge
aus der schweiz
klingt verheißungsvoll aber hierzulande
hat man ja nicht nur traumhafte
erinnerungen an diesen internationalen
wieder wettbewerbs sehr opa das bleibt
für mich aus kindertagen unvergessen
doch begonnen hat alles so schön wie im
traum
wer hat's erfunden die schweizer
[Musik]
an diesem ersten grand prix eurovision
de la chanson staaten sieben länder und
die schweiz holt gleich rang eins
[Musik]
daraufhin bat ließ pass jahr zwei
weitere jahre ins rennen geschickt 1963
ist es eine ausländische interpretin die
für schweizer jubel sorgt rang zwei für
die schweiz mit der israelin esther
offering denn entscheidend ist dass die
komposition aus heimischer feder stammt
35 jahre später beginnt die peinlichste
zeit der schweizer esc auftritte
[Musik]
grund liefert zwar ein paar schlagzeilen
allerdings die falschen
es folgt eine dekade der pleiten
ob neuer oder profi
da helfen weder knalleffekte noch gold
lametta das aktuelle berner musical
orientiert sich an nostalgischen liedern
wie diesen
[Musik]
unvergessen
petersburg sie waren vier mal dabei
[Musik]
ja
immer wieder kann die schweiz einen
ohrwurm platzieren
[Musik]
dienen
manch einer nutzt den esc als
karriereturbo so auch sandra studer
alias simon
ein highlight setzt aniko 1993 rang drei
[Musik]
doch die liebste erinnerung bleibt die
von 1988
[Musik]
die kanadierin celine dion holt für die
schweiz platz eins
[Musik]
und das ist der siegersong von damals im
neuen musical
[Musik]
ganz in seinem element christoph marti
von der musik kabarett gruppe
geschwister pfister
[Musik]
staub heißt es in der ersten probe mit
licht kostüm und maske aber noch ohne
richtige orchesterbegleitung fast im
fünf-minuten-takt rechtsposition
übergänge umzüge hier braucht es noch
arbeit
der nackte wahnsinn wie vor jeder
premiere wäre da nicht noch corona die
an spannung ist fast greifbar für
regisseur stefan huber und sein team ist
diese probe wie eine op am offenen
herzen
toi toi toi
[Musik]
zum stück dieses spielten einem
shoppingcenter das vor dem konkurs steht
ein biotop für ladenbesitzer angestellte
stammkunden voller sehnsüchte und
neurosen die szenerie eine erinnerung
des autors des musicals cihan inan an
seine jugend damals brauchte wohl jeder
sonntag untersuchen und dann ganz konsum
große konsumtempel in diesem tempel
tummeln sich einsame gestalten auf der
suche nach glück und liebe
stimmgewaltig tobias bonn von der
geschwister pfister
sein lebenspartner christoph marti ist
in der rolle der schillernde kiki auf
der suche nach sich selbst
[Musik]
ok ebenfalls mit von der partie
schauspielerin heidi maria glössner als
nymphomanin
[Musik]
sowohl die rolle gespielt
im langener theaterleute aber ein
explizit vulgären text handelt kann
nämlich auch hier müssen die parlamente
[Musik]
lust und frust klamauk und show
welcome to paradise city
[Musik]
die schweizer eurovision chansons sind
teils in die handlung dieser
kunterbunten geschichte integriert oder
bieten den figuren die möglichkeit sich
in eine bessere welt zu träumen
[Musik]
auf zu brechen zu neuen ufern
sie mit dem song achte bas sommer ja und
da sehen wir jetzt mit dem stoffmarkt
mit dem tobias bonn ihr sind ja gewöhnt
große musikalische fußstapfen traten
aber sehr ihn die ist das normal und
religiöse wahnsinn ein englisches ganzes
programm lang so lustig macht damit seit
jahren sie hat uns überhaupt nichts
getan einfach so angebote hatte die zeit
nun gut drauf hauen kommt und jetzt das
welche bedeutung hat der contest für
betreutes ausschusses ritual gesehen wir
gucken nicht jedes jahr den eurovision
song contest aber doch sehr oft eine
gelegenheit haben und nicht gerade
selber auf der bühne stehen oder so oder
dann noch nach der vorstellung den rest
schon eine logik janina sieg überhaupt
genug englisch ab den eurovision song
contest käse hält er das hat diese wm
distanz schafft also früher ist es das
ist cdu nach das war das highlight ist
ja dass er hat kleidung strecke kolonie
springen sozusagen wie ist denn das für
ein stil zieht das letzte halbe jahr und
auch jetzt die realität probe eben immer
kräftig anzieht wir sind natürlich
heilfroh dass wir hier was machen können
was das einzige dieses jahr
wir sind eine verschworene gruppe die
akteure auf der bühne zum team hält
merck stationen technikern und so weiter
die an kleider alle mit maske
ich habe wahnsinnig sexy cora es leinen
los
der call ist prof das mache meine augen
alle termine absage und natürlich gehen
wir wollen dass danach aber wenn das das
aussehen und ob sie theater dennoch geht
das ist immer noch riesig und eigentlich
sei sie wenn es auch in einem dauerhafte
und ich muss dazu noch sagen ich weiß
nicht ob das gleichsam dieses theater
hier das ist mein bisher schon mal am
arbeiter in theaterszenen ja gewusst das
ist das was ich mache musik als stünde
und immer große namen wie abba oder udo
jürgens oder so und da steht jetzt grund
sei unter der traumfabrik eurovision
song contest funktioniert das emotional
es ist wirklich schon schweizer
durchschnitts liegt vor mirós handeln
das ist das anders im wintersport wurde
von einer schicksalsgemeinschaft liegt
die aber gar nicht viel miteinander und
dann werden die ganz großen und die
ganzen kleinen probleme im sekundentakt
abgehakt und es ist ja schon in
identischer qualität die sd ist wirklich
gering und deshalb macht sich so viel
spaß
macht so etwas an deswegen ist offen
zwischendurch kommen
diese schweizer beiträge zurück wie
sehen sie die chance und dann ist es
plötzlich ganz großes kino und da ich
spüre alles und dann ist die musik noch
mal zu ändern sind wieder sieben
shoppingcenters kritik bisher nicht
profitabel
[Musik]
oder so köster kommt hier in bern erst
noch dazu allerdings wäre es nicht in
voller größe aufspielen können
aus gründen der korona sicherheit werden
zehn musiker weniger anwesend sein
ja einen ganz anderen weg wählt man am
opernhaus zürich damit das publikum
trotzdem in den vollen genuss kommt wird
dort ein ganz außergewöhnlicher aufwand
betrieben mehr noch die maßnahme ist
eine weltneuheit
[Musik]
wer oper kennt weiß nichts ist unmöglich
das ist illusion doch was macht die oper
in pandemie zeiten wo abstandsregeln
jegliche dimensionen von bühne und
orchestergraben spüren
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sie zaubert die opernwelt schaute am
sonntagabend nach zürich wie schafft man
es wären corona ausgerechnet boris
godunow diese prototypische chor oper
mit großer besetzung zu spielen
ausser zürich hat es bislang noch
niemand versucht es funktioniert obwohl
und gerade weil orchester und sogar der
chor nicht im opernhaus sind sondern
zugeschaltet werden
orchester hauptprobe fünf tage von
premier 7 uhr morgens im probesaal
orchester und chor live spielen werden
ach ja um 8 uhr normalerweise stehe ich
auch aber heute ist andere tag so dass
die übertragung funktioniert ist ihm zu
verdanken
rolex uhr gotscheff tonmeister des
opernhauses der hier im saal mit über 60
mikrofonen den ton von chor und
orchester abnimmt
ich kann kein klang 120 reproduzieren
ich möchte auch nicht unser live
orchester der mieter setzen
das ist klar aber was ich machen möchte
ich möchte einfach den klang erzeugen
der auch genauso hochwertig ist und auch
vielleicht jeder akzeptanz findet als
alternative klang für für den raum
ich möchte auch die leute damit auch
begeistern
live und ohne zeitverzögerung wird der
ton glasfaserkabel ein kilometer weiter
ins opernhaus gestreamt die solisten
stehen parallel auf der opernbühne
solowjow bekommt die signale der musiker
und muss sie per software im raum
anordnen so dass es authentisch klingt
eine der größten aufgaben die hier
gestellt worden sind
heute ist noch die letzte probe wann man
ausprobieren kann und auch sich fälle
erlauben kann
und das muss alles hier funktionieren
sonst hören wie die stille wie jetzt
dass wir das sonst
gibt es kein ton und keine übertragung
das kann ein nach einer falschen
bewegung sein und das ist schon alles
unterbrochen deswegen ist konzentration
ist ganz wichtig glaubwürdig soldaten
seien als ob das orchester eben im raum
säße er darf nicht zu laut sein darf die
solisten nicht überstimmen mehr als
sonst ist das team auf technik
angewiesen
das spürt auch dirigent carrey carla biz
vor allem die kommunikation auf distanz
ist heikel
hast du
so können jetzt bitte einmal klären war
aber dass felix ja sagen ja das sind die
verschiedenen kommunikations spielzeuge
für mich aus diesen zwei lautsprecher
kommt der klang von der bühne damit ich
hören kann was passiert und hier kann
nicht noch lautstärke dieses clans noch
ändern
also es gibt auch andere dinge habe ich
weiß nicht genau was das ist beginn
orchester hauptprobe höchste
konzentration
[Musik]
nico von royen wird auf die höhe
gebracht
das werden die zwei erwachsenen erzählen
über die jetzt mit luft
der ton ist fabelhaft nur bei der
kommunikation hapert ist sie reis
zwischenzeitlich ab
[Musik]
ja ich bin ein bisschen erschöpft
lisa so viele infos nahe so viele sachen
gleichzeitig laufen produkt
entschuldigen er hat mir die taste sich
verirrt er ja also ist es psychologisch
nicht einfach diese idee einfach ganze
zeit im kopf zu haben dass die sänger
sind nicht da fast etwas schief geht und
in der oper aber die sänger manchmal
bewegen sich anders an der vorstellung
und und was mache ich erlangt die
physische präsenz des orchesters das
dirigent wahrscheinlich verhindert dass
den höreindruck ganz abgesehen davon
dass der gleich ein anderes diese durch
die übertragung mit bester technik geht
etwas noren von dem wie es sich auch so
uns an hört und spürt das spektakel muss
man sich leisten können 250000 franken
hat intendant homoki investiert
zusätzliche personalkosten nicht
eingerechnet angesichts der tatsache
dass wir das eine ausgefallene
vorstellung aber um über 100.000
schweizer franken kostet hat sich das
bereits bei zweieinhalb vorstellungen
gelohnt
was soll ich sagen wir arbeiten ja sehr
international werden vertragliche
verpflichtungen und und wir sind dann
auch
wir haben dann bitte auch die
verpflichtung große oper zu machen
einerseits natürlich die verträge zu
erfüllen andererseits aber auch unserem
publikum gegen grasshoppers zürich soll
große sachen spielen
die premiere beginnt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
nach vier stunden ist klar das hier ist
weltklasse
das experiment geglückt carwitz
dirigiert ein wunderbares orchester und
der chor
diese leiden der russische seele ist zu
überwältigen und präsent als gäbe es
kein corona und rolex watch hat die
perfekte illusion gemeistert da ist sie
wieder
die magie der oper
beim nächsten thema da geht es um die
ungeschönte wirklichkeit schwarz sein
und europäer
das ist offenbar bis heute für viele
keine selbstverständlichkeit das zeigt
uns schmerzhafter junge autor und
fotograf john pitts sein buch europäisch
ist soeben auf deutsch erschienen es ist
eine beeindruckende reise durch das
schwarze europa wir haben john ibc in
amsterdam getroffen
dort sind aktuell seine fotos zu sehen
irgendwo in berlin an einem kalten
wintertag der fotograf john pitts der
lenkt den blick auf die frau in der
mitte und nancy afro perrin als ich das
wort ab europäisch zum ersten mal hörte
gefiel mir dass es meine vielseitigkeit
so schön beschreibt es zeigt dass ich
eine plurale identität habe jolie pitts
ist im nordenglischen sheffield in einer
arbeiterfamilie aufgewachsen die mutter
ist weiß der vater afroamerikaner der
ewigen frage nach seiner herkunft leid
entwickelte auto ein anliegen das ganz
normale leben schwarze europäer zu
zeigen
ich habe festgestellt dass schwarz oft
verzerrt dargestellt
die leute wollen schwarz um menschen
tanzen sie in ein partys karnevals oder
festivals ich bin bewusst im winter los
gezogen weil das einen viel tieferen
blick ermöglichen
ich verbrachte zum beispiel viel zeit in
den metro ich wollte schwarze menschen
zeigen wie sie ihre kinder zur schule
bringen oder zur arbeit fahren ganz
normale alltägliche menschlichkeit
seine fünfmonatige reise führt ihn nach
paris über brüssel amsterdam berlin
stockholm moskau marseille und lissabon
immer mit dabei sein notizblock und
seine fotokamera
[Musik]
hier sieht man ein stereotypes bilder
aus amsterdam eine frau auf dem fahrrad
gleichzeitig untergräbt ist aber die
klassische vorstellung einer rolle das
bild lässt keinen zweifel dass diese
frau aus holland ist und sie ist schwarz
auf seiner reise macht jolie pitts auch
einen kurzen halt in der schweiz
dieses bild habe ich in bern aufgenommen
es interessierte mich wie der
multikulturalismus im sinne der
kommerzialisierung weitgehend akzeptiert
ist
denn diese hand and werbung empfindet
nun wirklich niemand als und dann sitzt
hier diese frau mit den geschlossenen
augen in wirklichkeit blinzelt sie doch
es sieht so aus als hätte sie ihre augen
geschlossen und als würde sie bewusst
diese mächtige bildsprache um sie herum
ausblenden
[Musik]
johnny cage hat die vielen begegnungen
in einem persönlichen reise bericht fest
darin verwebt er sorgfältig die
geschichte der schwarzen in europa und
ihren kampf um anerkennung
die es im buch sind keine anklage
vielmehr vermitteln sie ein neues gefühl
für den alten kontinent
im original ist das buch bereits letztes
jahr erschienen
nun liegt es auf deutsch und anderen
sprachen vor und bekommt nun viel mehr
aufmerksamkeit
angesichts der aktuellen politischen
debatte um rassismus keine überraschung
für den jungen autor waren die
europäischen klubs merte demonstrationen
ein wichtiges zeichen der solidarität
das narrativ in europa war für ihn
jedoch zu sehr an dem der usa orientiert
in den usa wird sehr wichtige arbeit
geleistet aber manchmal wenn man
politische bewegungen eins zu eins
importiert importiert man auch probleme
die nicht unbedingt die eigenen sind
klar gibt es genauso viel strukturellen
rassismus in europa aber er spielt sich
auf eine ganz andere weise abreißen den
usa
er kann subtiler
in allen europäischen ländern haben
schwarze noch immer mit ausgrenzung zu
kämpfen
doch reicht dieses geteilte leid um
einen gemeinsamen europäischen geist zu
schaffen liegen die lebensrealitäten der
schwarzen bevölkerung in den
europäischen ländern nicht zu weit
auseinander
im buch berichtete autor auch von
begegnungen mit schwarzem europäern die
mit dem begriff europäisch nicht viel
anfangen können
trotzdem hält john pitts an der idee
eines vernetzten schwarzen europas fest
seine interaktive webseite apple.com hat
schon über 10.000 mitglieder und jede
und jeder kann hier etwas zu idee von
afro europa beitragen
es gibt in europa diese vielen länder
mit unterschiedlichen sprachen und doch
hält irgendetwas all diese länder
zusammen genau das möchte ich auch mit
putin erreichen
die schwarzen leute in europa müssen
begreifen dass es nicht nur um ihre
kleine community in dieser oder jener
stadt geht ist sie müssen begreifen dass
sie teil von etwas größerem es kann sehr
selbst der mächtigen 22 selbstportraits
markieren den anfang und das ende von
john pitts reise vom nordenglischen
sheffield bis an die mittelmeerküste im
italienischen ventimiglia pitts schreibt
ich schaute noch einmal in den nebel der
über dem meer hin und afrika werk und
schloss die augen
dann drehte ich mich wieder zum
stürmischen alten kontinent um
auf dem ich geboren und aufgewachsen war
und ging da hin zurück wo ich herkam
[Musik]
wir sind zurück in bayern hier feiert
paradise city am samstag uraufführung
das stück läuft über den ganzen winter
wer also eine portion leichter
unterhaltung sucht ist hier bestens
aufgehoben
nächste woche da wird bei uns archaisch
wir widmen uns dem thema geburt ich bin
gespannt
gleich jetzt geht's weiter auf 111 1 mit
dem report der markt kommen sie gut
durch die woche
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos